bonsoir virginie martin merci d'être
avec nous que vous évoque cette image
d'un président de la république gifler
en pleine rue d'abord quelque chose
aussi enfin il faut remettre les choses
dans leur contexte ont fait ça c'est
quand même pas la première fois que tout
ça arrive un journaliste qui ont direct
de l'elysée le disais il ya eu aussi des
choses bien plus graves pour le passé il
ya eu l'attentât du petit clamart à
l'encontre du général de gaulle il y a
eu aussi la tentative d'attentât un 14
juillet 2002 à l'égard de jacques chirac
vous voyez là on parle plutôt n'est plus
dans le registre je veux pas dire un peu
minimale mais voilà il faut quand même
relativiser raison garder ce que fait
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron puis après
aussi on peut penser à aux oeufs au
catch up à la farine aux tartes que les
sarkozy j'ose par hollande ont pu
recevoir par le passé aussi ou manuel
valls qui avait aussi eu un petit coup
physique comme cela donc la politique
quand elle dit en contact et de toute
façon souvent fait de violence ça veut
dire quoi vous la banaliser cette
violences en tout cas vous la
relativiser comme le fait d'ailleurs ce
soir emmanuel macron qui parle de faits
isolés d'un évident il y du ultra
violent vous êtes sur la même ligne
c'est à dire que je ne veux pas la
banaliser
on ne peut pas banaliser de toute façon
est un acte de violence qu'ils soient
réels d'ailleurs que l'avion soit réel
ou qu'elles soient symboliques ou
qu'elle soit verbale ou que c'est ça
c'est de toute façon très grave et c'est
un préambule et c'est normal mais
maintenant aussi il y a une façon de
dire c'est un fait isolé mais qui est en
même temps dans un contexte bien entendu
un contexte de tension de tension
politique de tension économique de
tensions sociales dont quelque part bien
sûr tout d'un coup le président de la
république à la fois par sa fonction
mais emmanuel macron women cristallise
de toute façon ses frustrations ses
colères ses wee cc tension et ses
inquiétudes aussi notamment post
confinement ça c'est une évidence mais
ya deux choses en fait emmanuel macron
et deux personnes en même temps si je
puis dire il est à la fois le symbole de
la république il est à la fois l'homme
politique emmanuel macron women comment
expliquer en tout cas cette gifle une
trop grande proximité ou la
détermination d'un évident yeux comme
d'un ami divy du comme on l'a dit le
chef de l'état il ne faudrait pas que le
président ça fera des barques foule
comme ça on sait très bien c'est une
grande tradition française que d'abord
c'est dingue foule donc on ne pourra pas
de toute façon changer cela d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron tout de suite retourne
au contact retour dans la foule
d'ailleurs même on peut même penser qui
derrière il capitalise cet événement
pourront faire après de la communication
politique
finalement à son bénéfice ça c'est
évident mais après on n'est pas dans une
tradition russe ou américaine où les
présidents sont évidemment harnachés
derrière comme ça des voitures
absolument délirante des services de
sécurité délirant et notamment aux états
unis
il ya quelque chose d'important qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que le président
ou éventuellement la présidente ne de
toute façon ne s'appartiennent pas ça
c'est important ils appartiennent à
l'année
sion américaine en france c'est pas
pareil le président peut être un jour
une présidente de toute façon sa partie
en lui même il fait un peu comme il
l'entend ça c'est une grande différence
aussi donc le contact le bain de foule
est une tradition à la française
rappelons-nous aussi des salons de
l'agriculture de jacques chirac jacques
chirac et pourtant on est loin du style
à virginie martin on avait un jacques
chirac très proche des gens on se
souvient de cette mémorable
effectivement au salon de l'agriculture
alors que on reproche en tout cas les
détracteurs du président de la
république les reproches une forme
d'arrogance est ce qui cristallise la
colère de certains peut-être bien sûr
bien sûr c'est à dire que emmanuel
macron à cultiver aussi de manière un
peu simultanée au début de son
quinquennat
vraiment une très grande verticalité on
se rappelle ils sont tous nommés jupiter
il a fait une intronisation avec cette
pyramide du louvre très solennelle on
avait retrouvé quelque chose d'autre et
monarchique très verticale très puissant
voire un peu narcissique qui gênaient
aussi et tout de suite après quelques
temps après il a aussi changé de braquet
et puis aujourd'hui la semaine dernière
on le voit joue en parlant extrêmement
mal sur les réseaux sociaux avec mc fly
et carlito d'aucuns peuvent dire qu'il a
désacralisé aussi la fonction tout en
faisant une verticalité et qu'elle a un
président relativement isolé ou ressenti
comme tel c'est toute l'ambiguïté aussi
peut-être du personnage une ultra
verticalisation peut-être bien trop
appuyé mais peut-être aussi une trop
grande horizontalité peut être elle
aussi trop appuyé est on obligé d'aller
jusque à parler de drogue sur les
réseaux sociaux avec mc fly et carlito
la question peut se poser sur la
sacralité
de la fonction alors quelles
conséquences pour cent en images quelles
conséquences pour pour son image c'est
une conséquence je pense finalement
plutôt bénéfique parce qu'il ya deux
choses à voir d'abord il ya l'événement
bon très bien cette tentative de j et
puis après il ya l'instrumentalisation
qui en kiosque et en effet ça c'est très
important c'est peut-être le discours
sur l'événement qui est plus important
étudier et là on voit bien que chaque
camp de gauche comme de droite
emmanuel macron inclus finalement
instrumentalise l'événement alors la
droite voire la droite dure radical dit
bien sûr que cris à la violence de la
société
cris a une trop grande finalement
démocratisation il faut qu'on revienne à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus dure
beaucoup plus sérieux que la justice
soit faite et cetera
et puis la gauche elle demande aussi
justice et notamment l'extrême gauche
avec 7 7 épisodes format mais selon
cette vidéo de papa sitôt d'une violence
inouïe inouïe qui appelle vraiment au
meurtre qui dit comment à la limite
assassiné des gens de gauche d'extrême
gauche de la france a soumises et là
aussi bien sur cette gauche-là réclame
qu'il n'y ait pas deux poids deux
mesures et ça c'est aussi quelque chose
d'important
et puis emmanuel macron qui dit tout de
suite je suis un peu tombé de cheval et
je remonte tout de suite en scène et
vous avez vu il ya eu des images
officielles qui ont été diffusées et là
tout d'un coup on entend au contraire un
président adoubé acclamé qui prend les
numéros de téléphone personnels de
chacun qui a ses problèmes et ses acquis
mais des petites lèvres dans sa poche
qui dit regardait cema brigitte et là
c'est la séquence émotion la séquence
intimité la séquence vraiment de là
cette mise en scène de la vie politique
contemporaine avec des séquences émotion
très forte trop fortes pourront dire
certains aussi merci à virginie martin
merci d'avoir été avec moi en direct sur
rt france